the problem of losing parameter bindings
is pretty widespread since any function
like set timeout that takes another
function as a callback may actually call
that function differently than you
expected callback functions are
inherently designed so that they will be
invoked by the system you pass them to
the zoo generally have very little
control over what the bindings will be
for the parameters of the functions that
you passed in for this reason you need
to be careful about all the parameter
bindings including the parameter this
whenever you pass a function as an input
to another function despite the fact
that you see an object on the left of
the dot when you pass the function in
this object will not be passed along as
the binding for the parameter this when
the system you passed it to eventually
calls your callback function one way to
pass a callback without complicating the
parameter binding situation is to pass a
different function one that doesn't
receive any parameters at all including
this then you just make room in the body
of that function for your custom code
and inside that area you reference your
method and then you can do the
invocation yourself passing along
whichever bindings you want for the
parameter this we've talked a lot about
the keyword this where it appears within
a function and some value may have been
passed in to be bound to it but what
would happen if we saw the keyword this
appearing in the global scope not inside
the body of any functions at all taking
a step back for a moment we should first
consider what we expect to happen when
we access parameters outside of the
function scope that they were defined
within what would we expect to happen
with this attempt to log the one
variable